[Music]
so we're really gonna do this it seems
that way yeah i get to live here with
you
can we talk about our future okay can we
be rebellious before we have kids oh yes
to making wonderful terrible decisions
you can see right in check out those two
what is he like a photographer
oh they're in love i don't think we
should spy on our neighbors
just because someone is allowing you to
look in on their lives doesn't mean it's
okay to watch how do we become their
friends
you want to become bffs with the
neighbors we now seem to be stalking
we just never done that before
[Music]
of all the eye clinics in the world she
walks into mine
this is crazy we totally hit it off hi
my husband is a complex individual
this might be a little problematic
i just wish we could hear what they were
saying
don't you ever feel guilty
it's like when you're so obsessed with
something
you forget to look around and go
what am i even doing
would it be strange if i asked to take
your picture
[Music]
why not enough for you
[Music]
hippo what did you do
[Music]
you